during my addiction for eight years but
eight years being a [ __ ] I prostitute oh
don't don't think I mean sitting uphill
selling my body hits a dope something
digs for two dollars jumping in and out
of cars this car that car til my face
wants to color the pavement you hear me
I mean just all the way out there would
I don't give a damn attitude but it was
just dope man I kept reeking with what I
always play somebody to come find me and
I go to him go to his house til someone
later he was requesting for me all the
time and made me and I'm just enough
sleeping really just him so you know
what happened out there I got hooked on
the man I hooked on the shelf don't kill
him fell in love with this dope dilip's
I wouldn't shake with nobody but him him
him I wanted a baby but I fell in love
with him I even moved in with him and
his mom his mom for some reason she
couldn't stand me but the dope dealer he
had a heck a heart problem he was on Jam
real bad he would always beat on me for
for the same stuff he was out there
doing if I might they're tricking he
knew what type of person I was before I
had started hooking up with him but he
was doing the same thing when he
couldn't find me he'll be up that trick
but he would always beat me for the same
thing that he was out there doing ain't
know what I fell in love with him and I
went to ask beatings I fell in love with
him moved in with him his mom he's
taking care of chilling with my ass he
got I don't know how many system but
only 11 of them living in the house and
I remember 11 adults living in one house
and you know what they always sit back
in chairs and recliner and watch this
[ __ ] beat the hell out of me mm-hmm and
I still wouldn't leave him and then when
my family will see me I cover it up I
would never tell them that he was
whooping on me and he really didn't have
no
the whoop on me is just still jealous
spirit that he had and on him he loved
me but he was jealous but I never had
quit slowing down
tricking with other men doe just cuz i
hot started feeling towards him next
thing you know I wanted a baby back hmm
took me a long time they ever want a
child I never want one but I wanted one
by this Hills been asked many he was
back to bow head with a big old belly
when we laid down in the bed I couldn't
go to sleep unless I was holding him not
him holding me I was holding him I was
always skinny when I was on drugs or
nothing then he got popped we had to
move out the house with his mom cuz me
and hung kept getting into it amazed to
shoot at me I just could feel the hair
of a bullet going by my by my ear cuz
he'll shoot at me you kiss me coming out
one of those smoke houses and that's
there I go up for the takeoff around him
I'm gonna leave my shoes I'm gonna be
barefoot he know country girl anyway but
it hurted me high as mom would treat me
and ask you what he encouraged him to
whoop me
she'd drink that hot Bush beer and she
lived a long time too I couldn't stand a
god forgive me anyway I ended up getting
pregnant and he didn't believe that it
was his child cuz he didn't believe that
I was honest screwing him but in the
biggest job he do my whole nine months
of pregnancy that man beating me with
anything he could get his hands on I
said I thought I was in love I thought I
knew what love was I was in love but I
thought I knew what love was
though what still stick with a man that
was beating the hell out of me with
anything then he got his hands on him -
I'll come check on me like he was a
football player now you running up
trouble a football playing you chuckles
at the legs and throw him up in there
and I never forget when that didn't do
me like that I never forget that so help
me God I took things out for him for a
long time I stayed out there in the
streets by year but when I got pregnant
and he got popped when I was son was
seven months old
it was incest in a family this man here
was still screwing his niece that they
had been molesting ever since she was a
little girl from was bullying the
brother the girl daddy she got burned
baby with bow daddy and then he was an
uncle uncle uncle still living wasn't
still [ __ ] this goddamn me see new
Sierra crack heavy he would use the
crane to get her to do whatever she he
wanted her to do when he got popped at
seven months and he went away he got mad
cuz I'm gonna send him some money to put
on his book [ __ ] I could I wasn't on no
child support I wanna no food stamps I
wasn't on no type of government
assistance hmm how could somebody want
me to send them some money number pill
raising my baby by myself my mom wasn't
helping me hang one up anyway she always
tried to use her money to try to control
me anyway up he got popped
he came out of jail I was some was six
years old when he came by day and I had
don't bother me our house was in college
and my second year of college at
University he stood downtown working for
Amelia Mars candidate the ones they make
Snickers three muscatel Milky Way
skittles and starbursts
I don't Bob me a house a three-bedroom
two-bath house for me and my foe yo I
don't build my money up a fire bank
accounts in the system was a CD account
for my son
Oh years old I couldn't believe it when
his mail first came he had his name
first and did me as the custodian
parents I thought that was so cool but
it was hard to for me it was hard good
when he got out I told him I wasn't
gonna never take him back maybe I'm
beating days was over with beating days
when oh he cries so bad he asked me
could he move in my house mind you the
Lord hid the Lord head don't bless me
cuz I had to grab on to the locker once
he went and got locked up that was it
that was it it wasn't nobody that capito
to pick up the backbone for me my child
what's the dope dealer yeah me the one I
fell in love with the one who I wanted
to baby back hmm why he locked up I
grabbed onto the Lord hey I know the
chart
I walked those streets at night I'm
saying self what 21 where I live with my
eyes up to the Lord but with her my help
hey my mom still had my child cuz I
middle ran off and left my child with my
mom you hear me
come I just instilled with kick in every
now and then cuz I was straddling the
fence one part of me wanted to do right
in one part of me still try to [ __ ] up
to finally I gave all of myself to the
Lord and I saw how the love was
overflowing my cover saying when I say I
was walking I know what it's like to be
all the way down I know what it's like
to give the Lord your mind body soul it
hot him well I don't know won't have
your heart he wants a whole heart if
they don't come to them double mine he
want you to come to a single mine I said
try to the Lord hey don't try to all
kinds of crackers get all kinds of dopey
[ __ ] why not try cuz I was at my last
rocker I couldn't take it I had I
already got suicidal I wanted to take my
life I don't try that three times
throughout my whole years mmm
started walking their Bibles Irene
meditating the word reading the Bible
day and night he say studying meditate
his word day and night David you read
the Bible and not walking it don't do
you no good
and when doing you no good but if you
walk it that's when you're following
instructions and there's something first
I couldn't understand their Bible beside
before that my mom knew man I already
been putting me in all these reels
before I fell in love with this guy you
understand me big book wasn't doing me
no good no rehabs all they do is talk
about the dope me when I come back out
I'll go right back to the drug see I let
the beat of the Bible be my big book I
started reading I start following the
mistress and I start getting in habit
practicing making a part of my routine
every single day dealing with today and
today only he tells you that in Matthew
7 verse 30 and 31 about don't worry
about something to eat
don't worry buy something to wear and
he'll tell you about don't worry about
tomorrow tomorrow take yourself
I've been dealing with monsters all my
life I let them let that demon come
moving I talked me into moving and I'll
go again huh Thomas in trying to do the
right thing my sister she be what am I
sitting with one minute but then to her
kids by another man did another since I
got she with one man but one up kid by
this man wasn't him nobody said me and I
said I'll trying to really was just
trying to set an example you know by
trying to make him with the father my
child by letting him come back in my
life cuz it wasn't it wouldn't be bad
for me to keep him away from our son but
I'll time he didn't try to build a
relationship with our child anyway I
still was to mommy and daddy to our
child
hey now no relationship it out to this
day they barely do have more I let him
go moving a house that the Lord had
blessed me with because I was godly I
let her ungodly me move into that house
and not thinking I'm thinking I'm doing
the right thing by trying to have a
relationship and make it with the father
of my child
but when thinking about one of us is
garlic and one of us is ungodly that's
in the Bible when he talks about an
equity yo hmm I still love this young
man nor there he was ungodly and I was
gone I'm the Lord have pictured where I
got such a good job I had all the bills
that a married couple where every time I
wanted me a new vehicle the Lord didn't
let me get it out the parking lot the
Lord had let me give my bugle up the
showroom blow Naoko silent no nothing no
none of it
I like gas water table alone my grass
and he doing probably Texas school Texas
homeowners insurance furniture all a
couple dad a married couple
just me my baby all that time so that
never came home and I lit another tummy
boom okay I'll go for that dick again
yeah I went he was
tonight was the dick
I stayed godly for a while for 14 years
I'm still with it was still with this
man you hear me I'm being a bread I'm
gonna bread that man didn't even have to
ever open up an envelope I bought him a
car to drive of work
I bought him on a drive on a weekend he
didn't have to go shopping for herself I
wouldn't get out of shopping for
everything I want to see you me the Lord
blessed me with so much money it's such
a good job about whatever I want to see
him and whatever I want to smell him in
what year I wanted to mess my his juror
had to mess mines customized I'm I'm
aware I'm Marquis in my ear three
carabao care and to carried on my finger
that boat carry used to be leaning so as
if it was a head now you have a head cop
legs due to the side on yeah that's how
that boat carriers to be I know head now
send me to the beauty shop to get my
hair did I my toes and they'll decide
[ __ ] didn't never neither I had a male
it's a guy that was a he owned Apache
oil in Pasadena by me being so ugly up
be out there in the field working for
Eminem Mars candy Casas that's a good
candy company and our competitor was was
Hershey I went to him and actually I'm
gonna give this man a job for me I paid
for our win on our honeymoon
you know that [ __ ] door ain't it was
sleeping a big wind and have no sex for
my honeymoon
Hadassah limousine I gave that man
everything that he could ever want did
he didn't even ask me [ __ ] Conan Lord
bless you with things and he old flow
you cope with blesses he expect me to
share that's why I tell you in Genesis
he said go and multiply be fruitful
proof was anything that's positive
anything that's pleasing to the Lord
sharing care and helping anything
praying pay my tithe say when I said I
walked it and it felt good I ain't gonna
never baby explain the feeling
I need that life back but I got a man in
my life and I need get life back with
the Lord all the way in my life Clady
won't for
when you say he's your shepherd you said
and I won't tell me instructions in that
Bible it's real just as soon as I'm
sitting here them instructions are real
to just follow we got so many evil
spirits around us in this year world
that you can't even see with your eye
he was spirits principality which cloud
much him same come saying it so his job
more than twenty folks ever he stayed on
that man and when that man could get his
way with me and may call himself luck in
that bedroom though it would me but my
son to kick that doe in my bed will go
in he coming out with her back it hurted
me that my son had to hear and see
something like that between me and his
father but it hurted me more and my son
had to come in now and rescue me too
just to get that man to stop hmm I got
them the best beating days was over way
hmm didn't think he'd come home still
put his hands on me as much as I was
given to him and doing for him huh he
didn't have to worry about nothing I
would be careful when I chew me one this
time hey man who done so much to me and
man him I live looking like Daffy Duck I
hear from my mom for two weeks of that
man that bust me and my mouth so bad
boom my lips you could have so I looked
I took some air but nothing with pipes
and news will meet with every day to
this day I still restrain stay well
because I love them
but I know now that that's not what love
is I had to learn that in first
Corinthians the whole chapter 13 it's
all about love I think my god is about
love and righteousness you know the back
you got to show them that you love them
you could tell God there to love him but
if you ain't snow in him I don't mean
donut damn he'll go out of action man
that's the same way you would have to be
in a relationship with somebody you
could tell them you love yeah I just saw
a person that you love
he said Ephesians 5 and 1 be imitators
of my funky look you know I love me look
good in the bed my good start I'll wait
my bad night now take the Lord for but
I'm going through some terrible a storms
and learn from a man
it seemed like everybody in my life of
monsters to me chilly day he called me
crackheads and everything but I'm a sane
woman who gave him every day I I told
you never find another woman who would
treat you like I did cuz I I was so
happy with my marriage I stopped I was
happy with my marriage too I dare you to
cleaning my house I dare you to wash
dishes I dare you took the washing
machine and dryer I'm gonna do it all
I'm gonna do it I for the never cook leg
don't know putting the pots and pans in
my refrigerator and everything in the
house I don't furnish the whole damn
house myself
and said man I can't even believe it I
found he was cheating with the H&R Block
woman it's cheating with the nice and
cheap man that devastated me too I
relapse
I had six years left for my house and I
would have been to paying for my house
you hear me
ain't been the same since I've been on
Josie ever since yeah him
I didn't let no man come in my life when
I was on them drugs put him eight years
I just thought [ __ ] that dick all the
time you hear me I'm like no goddamn
home like big dicks another day I'm
old-fashioned I'm antique oh [ __ ] in my
way I'm 57 years old
I'm at Redwood say I was cooking every
day working my job going school
full-time and being a PTA mom at the
school for my son when they have field
trips up in a good bit of shop around
and going to field trip with them to
help take care of the kids
yeah all the kids used to learn to come
to my house I want to spend the night we
had some demons in that house try to
stick with that man as long as I could
but when I relapse like I did and then
man did say it's okay you can get back
up you could do it again man and then
beat me up him my mama did they be my
anus did they beat me up we were they
tell you in the Bible you say that oh
the Tong full of deadly pause it
daddy cooked like a double-edged blade I
bleed it that's true I'm a witness to
that so I learned that in the Bible you
so much so I learned in the Bible they
just gonna have to take a man is going
to have the Lord his life on this round
it's gonna have to take of me and
soonerlater log o help me get that
monkey off my back
mmm so boy ain't Sitapur so no cat
something OD i still like gave up no
kidney i'll be trying to hit another man
be talking about I did so much man I did
it so much it from here jumping in I'm a
bunch of it I had to look 5 pounds and 6
ounces baby portal I'm preemie and you
couldn't get me have another bake I got
on the Brooklyn so Peter stayed on my
phone for 10 years straight hmm my cat
so smile man you were in my bed I'm
probably better than somebody young
women my bye
especially down there with my muscles
and stuff I take the Lord every day now
for you I talk to the Lord every day it
ain't a day that I'm damned and they go
by then I cannot leave you I cannot
leave you in my life when I walk through
here I'm always gonna look for next I
always look for your car and I be won't
stop just to see how you're doing I
don't be mourning I just know I'm going
to care about somebody who cares about
what my life was about running from me
just won't stop just to give you a big
old hood of me
big old hood I'm not gonna like it chill
bumps my nipples ghetto heart I'm just
gonna be honest with you it took me a
long time to learn how to be real with
myself before I could learn to be real
with others there's no sense with me
lying about it man I'm just gonna tell
you the truth I never take another black
man again I'm the type who like it's
okay for the man to cheat but then when
you cheat and you just go and you go all
the way backwards and you bring some
crack in my house Craig had never been
in that house ever since I got cleaning
the lock and the Lord blessed me with
that house and I closed on it and they
were locked up and they put me and they
got their mouse even I had bought me a
damn house you hear me
and you break some drugs in my house it
had me towed out eight eight years and
my son found it cuz his people also be
too he put his fitted one I'm shooting
there there was a pill bottle in there
that was the crack hmm you don't have to
go hang around other people for you to
read bring that so drugs well you know
by myself while the time cuz he in the
streets flipping around in the vehicles
that I'm about knowing one time did he
ever
ride me and I was running around one
time him in triple-a triple-a triple-a
Plus come on unlock the car hmm
so I could see what was in the car cuz
he had only one key about alpha cocaine
in the trunk him
I let their to set the lead up to me B I
start being unhappy cuz this is the man
that I was doing anything to make him
happy
you please him hmm - God does it I start
losing and spinning out of control and I
spend no more time with the Lord
well the lady say just to call it B over
there somebody called me on my phone it
wasn't a lady but it was my yard man
come out who do my yard you say you're
calling with at that house right now I
jumped in my truck
Oh enjoy I'm a Silverlight person I had
3000 GT
280zx Camaros today with the Tahoe I'm
jumping their child went over there and
blocked my cowlick here that I bought
for him black history and I'll take that
back
blocked his quarry hmm we don't dare to
the door knock knock on the door next
time nope open it oh hey hey my girl
likes my hand girl likes [ __ ] steel head
girl like I told the two pillars up 32
to 38 I call him Billy Bob and Betty I
love hanging out at the gun range every
week with my home girl named Stacy white
girl I like stuff like that they
wouldn't open the door they crack that
dome they crept it though I problem I
put up there instead though so they can
close the door cuz I push that door out
all the way up they come to bring his
[ __ ] ass up out of you I said I
finished you cheering your kneecap and I
thought about how he used to beat me I
said nothing [ __ ] you and your kneecap
and give you a limp for the rest of your
life mmm
he took out running down smash down the
street he couldn't get in the car take
out cuz I had to pulled up and block the
car
I had to talk to me to come back in
getting in the car and bring the car to
the house you can tell me what is what
stop begging still my little I don't
start begging the stuff and let him
leave
oh dear you start staying at the end
child sweet and [ __ ] left me with every
single bill of worth Edna gonna say all
me help you on your bill which I need it
anyway huh but then I don't I spent out
of control this dog chasing after him
stop stop associating with the Lord
you'll stand me it went all about the
Lord no more all about that dick yeah me
oh well it's probably only deep that you
[ __ ] you get crazy about a deal get
sprung on it - I wish I was 37 years old
before I let a man ever eat on me and
sit there I've been locked my kneecaps
around a person Nick I'm not never baby
hell that problem make me sprawl - out
of me to live one dude they took me
outside I better lost my mind you hear
me
that man wouldn't be able to part for me
being that smelly you hear me I'm gonna
tell you the truth I love being real now
I went to somebody care but to be real
hmm to this day I called him every now
dad but his father's day I sent him a
text message he won't he won't send them
back he'll say that he talked to my son
he talked out some more more dinner
tonight so she a with him huh but his
life ain't been say cuz he's the type to
give me a hundred fifty for Mother's Day
they say what you don't get my son gave
you a thousand dollars
I'll put it on a prepay course and could
do whatever you wanna do it the sky's
the limit
you got the Lord and you'll I just had
to live when you're so happy
are you so you wouldn't think about this
yes three all my strength was coming
from the Lord everything I had was
coming from the Lord
before I let him come in my life and me
no me no I was giving me everything I
want everything you missed a lot of fun
in the righteous way he'll give it to
you he'll give it to you if you send a
righteous way go give it to love to say
well let me hit the lotto law you ain't
finna hidden I even be down with
something like that he said that one I
made a difference in a lot of people's
lives in my family he was like I was
taking care i was the bread in my own
house it had to be the bread and else
the same one that stood up again shooter
just associated with me because of my
addiction when a house fell in the
foreclosed they called me when one got
pregnant for another man knowing you got
to see a man they calling me for 600
cell phone the boys out one day night
they all see this hill this video I mean
because ain't none of it is alive no no
dead mother man
I even had no one doing me so good I
even had her own allows every other week
hundred dollar she asked me the same
question what you want me to do okay
what'd you do with it put it on one of
your bills I'm gonna get some that you
wanna get but you can see how their
sector with me not this time when I do
grab back on the Lord Holloway and I've
been taking my baby steps this journey
gonna be oh wait it's gonna be all
whisper me soonerlater I believe it mmm
and I'm I'm come off to steal crack all
the way then I'm gonna give all of me
again
this ain't gonna be round truth it's
gonna be stuck the time I know what I
did for me to relive and I never do it
again I learned from I never slack up at
nothing to ever got something to do with
the Lord
I'm always no matter how good your dick
is how good you eatin how have you I
never changed was the Lord he gonna be
my ego I'm a mister I keep you in my
everyday I don't never want to come back
to this type of life ever again in life
to live like this all I do is suffer and
touching myself he keep asking me how
long my child you gonna keep being
foolish and I say you show right
and he'll play one egg like it did he's
awake like a tick he'll be a Polish I
already know what the dope I already
know the Graham O'Neal steeper and I
already come to help arrest I already
know he won
well what's taking you so long what's
taking you so long
hmm and he right and I can't even have
[ __ ] I can't even answer but I learned a
lot
I'm steady being my Bible I'm still cold
my scriptures because when you don't
evil spirits who make you make your body
at home what do you want them to be a
home and I know you keep them don't
worry us the words this is a weapon they
destroy they destroyed then go to the oh
my god you hit me mmm damn flee from
that it's hard for me grab on to the
Lord this time and ain't even no
journals as bad as I was the last time
but eventually I am gonna do it and I
got a I got a big reason for me coming
back in business in California huh it's
lonely you here I will be coming back
i'ma show you don't just like you have
to show the Lord that you love him cuz
he's a God of action I have to show you
too that you play a big part in my life
I have to show you that show you that
and it's a reason for me stated and
constantly knob to see you it's a reason
behind and I better take heed to it
that's a lot of money I get from you so
I can't don't know we go Oh give me
money I gave I'm you not even a penny
man not even a penny not hard there for
me it's hard for me not to spend any of
your money
but I'd be doing be doing it and I
spending none of those rows yeah I
thought I couldn't do it at first
thought I couldn't do it but I can't let
getting just getting easier and easier
I'm going over there
ice cream making me happy chocolate ice
quick I'm going straight over there give
me paint a chocolate ice cream I got my
clothes like the way wash my clothes
come back clean clothes clean pajamas I
wept all my underwear be torn secretly
and send me my beard I need to go send a
payment in on them you know my life is
what I make up I do not try not to block
around these and certain crowds they
don't want nothing give me I'm not
better than you but in order for me to
change it'll be a little bit I I had to
learn how to cut some of my loose and
it's more than cuddling forgive me and
I've been cutting answers alone they
don't know me well for me I don't wanna
be looking out for my well-being this
the Lord and maybe you I appreciate you
listening to me sooner or later to talk
about my life it's not gonna hurt and be
painful to me no motion later
all right Alicia thank you so much for
talking to me again
love listen to you you're gonna end up
being a real good friend you gonna be
one of my good friends you watch to see
what I take mark my words I'm claiming
it in the name of Jesus how you do is
help us all day long all of us all of us
without were some man you know we you
know we'd be ready to [ __ ] up but it's
one of us on your whole bunch got to try
to be good it's me it's me
you